Okay.
Time to debate movies again.
Which movie are we talking about this week?
The Jackie Robinson one.
42.
Good.
I know exactly how I feel about that movie.
Yeah, well, Im going first.
I dont care how you felt about it.
I think the movie is good.
And my first reason is Chadwick Boseman.
Alright?
Hes the main reason this movie is good.
Whose butler is that?
Hes not a butler, hes and actor.
He plays Jackie Robinson.
In the movie 42.
I thought that was Wesley Snipes.
Are you sure youre not a racist?
Like, have you dug deep into your soul?
No, its not like that.
Its just that I didnt look at him all that
closely, to be honest.
Hes in every single frame of the movie!
What were you looking at if you werent looking
at him?
Other stuff.
Alright well if you didnt know it wasn’t
Wesley Snipes—who was in prison when they
shot this movie, by the way—then you definitely
don’t know whether the performance was good
or bad.
Im taking a point.
(That was easy)
Its mine.
Im up.
One to nothing.
Thats fine.
Thats okay.
Because Im going to catch right back up with
my first point, which is the Disney-fied racism.
Why do you have to keep making up new words?
Why cant you just use words that are already
in, you know, accepted English language use.
Theres a ton of them.
Disney-fied racism is when they take the feel-good,
don’t-ruffle-anybodys-feathers cloth, and
wipe it vigorously over any scene that has
to do with racism, rendering them basically
harmless.
You thought the scene where the opposing manager
said the n-word three thousand times in a
span of about five minutes was harmless?
No, no, I dont.
Thats the point.
That one scene the movie has the balls to
go for it.
Yeah.
Alright, but every, other scene that has to
do with racism, they cop out.
They take the soft way out.
I mean, people called him names.
His teammates didnt like him at first.
Come on.
The real Jackie Robinson had to deal with
more than that in just a single day of his
life.
I dont even know what to say.
(That was easy)
Alright fine, my turn.
Harrison Ford.
I thought Harrison Ford was awesome in this
movie.
What?!
Come on!
You didn’t like Harrison Fords performance?
Come on, you didnt like him?
He was so far over the top he went sliding
down the other side, man!
You did not just say that.
I know you didnt just say that.
If he had been any more cartoonish they literally
would have had to call his character Burgermeister
Meisterburger.
So a guy has an accent and a little bit of
a limp, and hes a cartoon?
Dude he has Popeye face that whole movie.
Come on!
This is not even up for—you know, case closed.
(That was easy)
Im taking the point.
You cant just say case closed and have the
case--
Another problem I had was the speechifying.
Again with the speechifying.
Here we go.
How many inspirational, motivational speeches
do you think the real owner of the Brooklyn
Dodgers gave the real Jackie Robinson in his
entire career?
Im sure I have no idea.
One?
Two?
Sure.
In this movie, which only covers, like, two
seasons by the way, he gives twenty seven
inspirational speeches to Jackie Robinson.
Come on.
Alright, they could have called this movie
Lincoln 2: The Baseball Years.
Yeah, with 130-something year old Lincoln.
That makes a lot of sense.
Harrison Ford is just about old enough to
play an unassassinated Lincoln.
Oh come on now, he's only 70 years old.
Did you know Lincoln was assassinated on Jackie
Robinson Day?
No.
I mean, it wasnt Jackie Robinson Day at the
time, but its the same date.
April 15.
Dont you think thats kinda kooky?
Maybe we should just call it a day here, man.
I mean, its not--
The other problem I have with the film is
the little racist boy in the audience.
He hears his dad say the n-word and so he
says it too, in the cheesiest scene since
the ending of The Postman.
(That was easy.)
You really dont like The Postman, do you?
Another problem I had was that Sammy Sosa
has a cameo in this movie in the stands.
What?!
Im like 85% sure it was him.
Why would they give Sammy Sosa a cameo in
this movie?
Because he played baseball.
So did Cal Ripken.
Yeah, but hes not African American.
Neither is Sammy Sosa.
Now whos an idiot?
You.
The answer to that question is always going
to be you.
Sammy Sosa is Dominican.
So hes an African Dominican?
Wow, they are really going to call you racist
after this video.
No, hes from the Dominican Republic.
It’s a country.
Is it anything like the Banana Republic?
Yes.
Its right next door.
Oh, well, then I know where that is.
You might know the store on the other side
too.
It’s called the Notary Public.
Yeah, what do they sell?
Stamps.